[Música]
[Aplausos]
cala de imagine esse sim com um
autocolante na testa um autocolante que
diz aos outros
dá uma expressão clara sobre como
responder cada vez que fala com este
exercício que eu fiz com um grupo de
professores em que colocou a vitória em
mente na testa cada participante um
autocolante com uma mensagem diferente e
essa mensagem pode ser rico quando eu
falo ou concorda com tudo que eu digo ou
simplesmente calote
este especificamente esta casa tem uma
história
a professora ficou com esta autocolante
na testa entrou na discussão que eu
tinha que fazer a seguir
e nessa discussão as pessoas têm que
haver uma interação de discutir um
tópico qualquer e toda a gente sabe o
que está escrito na testa das outras
pessoas - o próprio
a idéia é que nessa interação tem que
respeitar aquela instrução
esta pessoa que ficou com este calor
entrou na discussão como professora
confiante que era e no momento em que
apresentar as suas ideias
alguém dizia quem é que como eu vi
muitas vezes esta palavra
cala te e muitas dessas vezes na escola
fala isso agora não é importante
cala te deixa agora outro responder por
ter tido uma boa oportunidade de ficar
calado quando era miúda o city o que eu
mais gostava de história na escola e
outra a escola era sócrates era mesmo
aquelas afetadas porque na sala aprender
coisas novas todos os dias
ainda hoje se ainda hoje adora a escola
quando vou trabalhar com professores
entra numa escola e vejo um grupo de mil
diz a sair
o vídeo ficou mesmo só observar a si
mesmo em do fida ensinada às vezes mesmo
piada com aquela energia toda a minha
escola é espetacular e os professores de
professor sam fica até quarta
e quanto mais conheço os professores mas
acho que eu sou espetacular porque eles
fazem tanta coisa quanto um pouco dentro
de seu servo não querem como disclaimer
só pra avisar que a minha visão da
escola e nunca nem vi a zada mas vamos
voltar ao exercício e vamos voltar
aquela professora ela no final quando
estávamos a discutir o que tem
acontecido estava visivelmente
incomodada iria nunca me senti tão mal
que horror
durante o exercício estava sempre
lembrar que tenha uma azul né
finalmente possível que o que ela sente
que horror
desde pequenina que a comunicação que eu
dei conta que as pessoas comunicam de
forma diferente e e essa diferença tem
um impacto muito e fred lembrou
e lembra muita gente sentir como é que
esta pessoa foi capaz de dizer
exatamente aquilo que eu penso que o que
eu sinto
na altura pensava bom é preciso ser um
escritor muito talentoso e para
conseguir dizer exatamente aquilo que
ela forma as palavras e esta capacidade
e as usar
assim desta forma tão natural sempre foi
para mim uma coisa que é uma entusiasta
mutantes quanto entregou já mais tarde
na faculdade
tem o professor que quando explicar como
é que o desenvolvimento acontecia ou não
acontecia da voz quente exemplo vamos
considerar a linguagem e conscientizem
imaginei mãe cantar chamar o seu filho
para jantar em uma determinada parte da
cidade pode dizer uma algo desse gênero
o jogo embora deixou a bola ainda melhor
se for por outra parte da cidade já pode
ouvir algo como ao joão maria ganha pra
dentro vai aguardar a bola naquela caixa
verde que estava perto da janela lá no
quarto e quando ia pra baixo passa na
casa de banho lavar as mãos e vamos
jantar que é má festival de frango o
nosso vocabulário
enfim o nosso pensamento - palavras
menos pensamentos e menos pensamentos
menos desenvolvimento menos envolvimento
mais pobreza a todos os níveis
então a comunicação sempre andou ali à
minha volta
até que há oito anos atrás um colega um
desafio para pensar num curso de
formação de professores onde hoje
pudesse ajudar a gerir situações de
conflito na sala dava a minha primeira
experiência foi na escola num
agrupamento de escolas em gaia e desde
então já teve com centenas de
professores e é sempre assim é sempre 11
experiência extraordinária porque para
eu estou eu não sinto que eu adoro com
pessoas são as pessoas que eu acho que
são espetaculares a trabalhar aquilo que
eu mais gosto
a comunicação ea oito anos atrás eu
entrei na escola estava contatando
galinha e não era porque estava
emocionada
não desta vez era porque durante três
horas e ao longo de oito semanas
eu ia estar numa sala com 11 pessoas a
trabalhar como tendências de comunicação
medo mas mais ou menos como eu esperava
as pessoas foram espetaculares e foi
extraordinário para ali estava eu a
propor para gerir em sala de aula o que
tinha que fazer era usar uma ferramenta
usará a comunicação como ferramenta isso
tudo especificamente algumas estratégias
muito específicas e que seriam muito
poderosas
isso é muito difícil aceitar que para
lidar com um problema que anunciava como
algo que este técnico geracional
familiar mas a social resulta de uma
forte crise de valores
então eu tenho que mudar a forma como
lhe comunico tem muito difícil mas por
questões particulares e não existem e
fazem coisas extraordinárias e quando
aprendem colaborar é mais natural que a
competir quando aprendem que a
comunicação positiva começa com escuta
quando aprendem que a diferencia é
quando acontece quando eu procuro aquilo
que é comum com o outro e não e não
simplesmente é aceito a diferença quando
eu sou capaz de expressar forma positiva
e negativa e quando aprendendo que esta
capacidade não colocar nos sapatos do
outro sem tirar os maias
esta capacidade se chama empatia que é
muito difícil dizer
volver e por isso todos todos têm que
ajudar quando estamos a ouvir e
treinamos as perguntas a arte de fazer
perguntas como promotor do
desenvolvimento ou quando praticamos
mensagens e o ou quando praticamos o
elogio ou quando nos damos conta de como
é difícil mudar a forma como comunicamos
e como pode ter tanto impacto como teve
com aquela pessoa coisas extraordinárias
acontecem por exemplo a certa altura uma
pessoa dizia que havia alguma coisa é
desde o princípio do lobo este primeira
semana que não marcou uma falta de
treinar
estávamos em fevereiro ou uma professora
que jogou num livro você não mostra das
cores e passou a aplicar uma hora todas
as sextas-feiras trabalhar as emoções
com a sua turma
outra professora de português
usando um pequeno vídeo de um filme
passou uma aula a perguntar coisas como
a que é que acham que acham que porque
ela está sentindo e porque com ela
abordará a 0
eu acho que devemos deixar o andré dizer
a turma porque ela está magoada
esta é a minha experiência não é o único
nem e super inovadora não sou o único a
fazer isto por exemplo outro dia
encontrei um blog e uma professora
o blog chama cativar na escola é muito é
muito fácil não é cativar pedrinho não
procurem agora está ativar na escola
isto logo
é e de uma professora que está quase lá
da forma fria e silva e quando estava em
o que ela faz é trabalhar levitação
trabalhar técnicas da regulação
emocional
escrevi sobre isso nesse bloco em
escolas do agrupamento no agrupamento de
escolas de leiria enquanto tentava falar
com ela e lhe perguntei a primeira
começou a fazer esse trabalho
as formações e depois lhe umas coisas e
comecei a perceber que isto é importante
então quem que suporta seu trabalho
eu faço isso nas minhas horas livres
muitas vezes e às vezes por carolice
ora digam lá ou não se as pessoas não
são espetaculares
uma estratégia que é muito mais certeza
que há dezenas centenas de trabalhos e
projetos experiências que estão a
acontecer neste momento nas escolas e é
desses projetos que todos temos que
falar
é disto que nós temos que ouvir falar
quando ouvimos falar da escola
temos que trazer aquilo que nós sabemos
sobre comunicação que investiga santos
ensina sobre a comunicação
temos que trazer isso pra escola é claro
que até pra mim que adora a escola em
que as pessoas são espetaculares que tem
pra mim às vezes é difícil e apetece
desistir e há momentos em que ouviu os
sabonetes velas tem muito bonito mas se
não tem tempo tem programa aprovada não
há tempo para fazer estas coisas ou
quando ouvimos
eu acho que os miúdos não entendem a
linguagem da violência e na
agressividade
nessas alturas é difícil mas eu peço
agora vai pensar
é nos talvez menos ainda pouca gente
importava submissas lavar os dentes
durante quanto tempo e quantas vezes e
agora o estado oferece cheques dentista
existem escovas com temporizador e
depois também penso que as pessoas são
espetaculares e fazem coisas
extraordinárias com muito pouco e eu já
havia mudança acontecer também atenção
aos seus pensamentos porque elas vão
transformar de maçã tomar atenção às
suas ações porque elas vão
transformar-se em âmbito da atenção aos
seus hábitos porque elas vão formar o
seu caráter
então atenção ao seu caráter porque vai
definir o seu destino
estas são as palavras numa grande tarde
feliz eo a watson a nossa comunicação
modela o nosso comportamento
uma comunicação mais positiva é mais
restritiva resulta num comportamento
mais positivo mais ativo e isso
significa mais desenvolvimento e mais
desenvolvimento significa menos pobreza
a forma mais natural de comunicarmos é
só aquela que mais repetitivos e pois
nunca vamos saber o que realmente
estamos a silenciar quando dizemos
estava
[Aplausos]